so Steve tell us about how you booked
dumb and dumber 2 that was interesting
Rick Montgomery the casting director
months before my audition called me in
to his office on a sort of a bogus
commercial guy was a real commercial he
was casting but he didn't really want to
see me for the commercial he wanted to
just get me in the room and asked me if
I would be willing to come out and play
with these guys that were making dumb
and dumber 2 t.o and I said yeah of
course I would love to do that okay well
we got a couple of things to iron out
and at that time warner brothers was
still attached as the producing studio
and I didn't hear anything for a few
weeks or a month and then all of a
sudden big news and the trades was
Warner Brothers dumps dumb and dumber 2
and there were a number of reasons that
they used as their excuse why they
didn't want to be attached to the
project anymore and I just thought at
that point that it's dead and you know
story of my life you know I get this
close to something amazing and and and
it blows up but then pretty soon after
that Universal jumped in and snapped up
the project in conjunction with red
granite which has picked up and
distributed lots of smaller interesting
films that a lot of other bigger studios
didn't really have any interest in for
example the wolf of Wall Street as one
of those films and so red granite and
universal became involved with dumb at
number two and now we're back on again
and the audition was scheduled and I was
ready with the material and I was
excited about it and I went in and I was
expecting I knew that the directors were
going to be there Peter and Bobby
Farrelly but I was expecting sort of a
normal audition scene scenario it's just
a small room with a few people in it and
a video camera and and we do our thing
and I leave well I walked into the room
and it was a screening room in an office
building and with theater style seating
and there were 25 or 30 people smattered
throughout the seats and these big flood
lights shining down on on me and a video
camera there and pete and bobby farrelly
sitting in the front row and it kind of
threw me a little bit it just wasn't the
audition situation that I was used to
and so we chatted for a little while I'm
not a big audition chatter I don't like
to do that I like to get on with the
material and do my work and then leave
the room quickly but they wanted to chat
and there's Oh Steve we're so happy to
have here we feel like we know you we
see and everything and and tell us a
little bit about yourself oh I'm
thinking oh really so I told him a
little bit about myself and where are
you from I'm from Denver Colorado grew
up in denver colorado oh really your fan
of the Broncos oh no don't I don't want
to talk about sports I really don't but
we did and we talked about the Broncos
and and how they were going to do this
year and I said the Super Bowl Super
Bowl all the way I just had no idea that
they were going to perform so poorly at
the Super Bowl but and then we started
the audition and I had the first line in
the audition so said my line and the guy
reading with me came back with a line
that wasn't on the page and I looked
down to make sure it was another page
and it wasn't there and I said are you
sure you have the most recent revision
of the script and by that I mean you
don't so can you get that now my
momentum is kind of thrown off and we
have to pause and wait while he goes to
get the
the correct Verde updated version of the
sides and then he came back and we
proceeded and there were there were some
other technical problems that were that
forced us to start over again and it's
the situation is just deteriorating
rapidly and finally I just I completed
the scene actually we did two scenes i
completed the scene and i said thank you
very much guys have a great shoot and
thanks for having me on and i left i was
fuming i was fuming smoke could have
been coming out of my ears I was so mad
because I was the crash-test dummy all
these things had gone wrong that I had
no control over I I couldn't control any
of these things and I felt it was the
worst audition of my life of my life and
I was the crash test dummy for the other
guys waiting outside who were going to
go in and those things wouldn't happen
to them because they would have all been
corrected by the time they came into the
room and I knew that I did not have this
job I knew it and then a couple of weeks
later didn't hear anything finally the
phone rings and my agent told me that i
am the directors first choice well you
could have knocked me over with a
feather I I just couldn't I couldn't
believe it and she said don't get too
anxious don't get too excited because
there's still some hoops we have to jump
through you have to be approved by the
producers and then at another level by
the studio and once we get over those
hurdles then we can start to breathe a
little bit and and but your pee tanabe
fairlies first choice and I thought well
go figure and there's an old saying and
I you know I keep on trying to remind
myself of this every day and sometimes I
forget like in this instance the saying
is you cannot feel your own handshake
meaning that basically you just are I am
in no way capable of evaluating how
other people see me I just can't do it
you know would that we could see
ourselves as others see us and
while we were shooting we had a setup
break and and I I asked Pete Farrelly
why was I cast in this thing I thought
it was the worst audition of my life he
said you know you were the first guy
into the room and it's very very rare
that we ever cast the first guy that
comes into the room I he didn't remember
when he had ever done that but the
reason he cast me was because there was
one line that I was supposed to be
delivering to my adopted daughter that I
delivered in a very sweet patient loving
way and everybody else who came into the
room was annoyed with her and angry with
her and that's not what they wanted they
wanted that they wanted to see that
relationship of total unconditional love
and acceptance under any circumstance
and that's that's the choice that I made
and that's what got me the role
you